prior to their match Anish Geary
asserted that despite his respect for
nihal sarin's speed chess play he was
eager to play anyhow in Rapid and felt
that they were evenly matched in their
semi-final in the chess.com Global
Championship but I think that this time
control is Maybe
I I don't know of course him well enough
but I think this is the time control
where we probably match our strengths I
I hope so at least I think probably in
the classical I would think I'm still
stronger in the Bliss he is stronger
already but maybe this rapid format is
where we are evenly matched but maybe
I'm wrong and I'll get uh smoked you
know we'll see but I I do think that I
should have a good shot the first game
showed the kind of precise conversion on
excellent opening preparation that Gary
is famous for and he went smoothly in a
fine game if H3 is played do not take it
with your Pawn that's the only trick
black has left but there is a
resignation Anish giri wins game one and
a very deserved victory for the Holland
player yeah this is a great win for
Anish I mean getting the momentum right
into the match gives him confidence then
however Nihao immediately struck back
with a game that was just as convincing
as anisha's initial Victory this was but
the first comeback from nihal who seemed
absolutely unfazed by stress throughout
the match and it can't go to the queen
side because I went to see one of the
rookie two checks kings in the corner
now and he goes Rook A7 a7's over that
pawn is promoting
it takes game two here Anish giri just
trying to find the resignation button
there it is a little head nod he ties it
up yeah that was that was super
impressive I mean such a clean game
getting almost nothing from the opening
but a little bit of advantage two more
more turbulent games ensued and in both
Nihao put giri under a lot of pressure
and was winning objectively at points
resourceful play from Geary and some gas
from nihal kept the match even in the
final moments of the day Nihao was even
lucky not to lose the end game as a
blunder allowed Geary to pick up an
extra Knight
King F6 okay he's winning yeah he's
completely winning three or something
King I mean some move it's not that easy
though White's gonna go F4 if you move
the Knight F4 Flanders at four
oh my God and and oh Knight D4 F5 and
then G5 E5 check and it's a draw oh how
about the wind was so hard I didn't see
the win I didn't see the wind there oh
and Neal pulls it off yes now you just
have to know oh you've got Anish is just
he is just kicking himself right there
this is a oh
he was hoping for a king F1 free move
yeah wow yeah you gotta go up and down
here he's trying to every every trick in
the book what was that
yeah he's gonna stick around he usually
gets up and leave I've never I've never
seen that might be the wildest finish to
like a nehal siren game I've ever seen
and the hall is a bit rough today yeah
making a lot of very uncharacteristic
kind of time pressure mistakes but two
to two is uh I'm seeing the computer
when it was really difficult I I'm not
blaming Gary for a sec he's playing him
playing himself I'm not blaming Anish
for a single second for not finding the
win heading into day two Nihao could no
longer be considered an underdog against
Gary by any Observer and it was clear
Anything Could Happen
foreign
just as on the first date Gary opened up
the match with a very convincing game
maybe his best of the match as his
strike with 15 Rook takes H5 and then
Knight takes E5 earned two brilliant
annotations from game review and claimed
a big Advantage he never let it go
Fabiano caruana deemed it a perfect game
from Gary Escape via those dark squares
that could just like slide across the
knights or controlling some squares but
not quite enough and yeah this is uh
this is game over this was a perfect
game by Anish this was a beautiful
Victory and it goes to show that maybe
you shouldn't deviate as early as move
one because when you play an opening
like one Knight C6 you get yourself in
trouble from the very start and for now
Anish Kiri takes the lead once more you
see game one you see game five he is an
early riser for the second time in the
match Nihao was down but he proved
himself The Comeback Kid five head
opening play in this game and throughout
the match particularly impressed Fabiano
caruana who has long frustratedly bashed
his head against Gary's renowned prep
Nihao got a nearly winning position out
of the opening and the commentators were
virtually begging Geary to sacrifice his
Queen for two minor pieces and practical
chances as Magnus Carlson had once
famously and successfully done against
Geary and if you play Bishop E4 this is
the queen sec I was about to highlight
is Rook F4 takes takes you've two minor
pieces and a pawn for the queen this is
anything but clear you know I do like
this decision practically ultimately
Nihao closed out game two accurately and
beautifully with the brilliant 28 Bishop
to H6 which re-tied the match anytime
soon you can make others you can make oh
my oh but that that's clinical I think
that's actually Checkmate isn't it like
how do you avoid Checkmate in this
position that's so nasty that that's a
brilliant move if we'll just show up G
takes H6 it's Checkmate in three and the
King runs away but this is getting just
more and more upsetting if you're Niche
Geary he took a one-game lead and
immediately he gets destroyed by nihal
sarin and that's game yeah he didn't
want to look at this position anymore
look he didn't develop any pieces
after these turbulent battles the
players Reign things in with two more
solid draws in game seven and eight as
the players proved willing to settle
things in Armageddon
Geary had the greater desire for the
black pieces as his bid of 12 minutes
and 57 seconds secured the draw odds
Nihao meanwhile came in with a big bid
of 14 minutes and 15 seconds showing
clearly that he wanted to play White and
he wanted to win
complex Place saw the advantage change
hands in the early moves but things
clarified after Gary sacrificed his Pawn
on B6 to simplify matters he was
grabbing his forehead he knows this is a
very tense spot because this might shape
the rest of the game and he's grabbed it
Bishop D4 we actually saw Knight to C4
not your Great Mouse slip Rook C4 no he
puts the Knight on C4 he trades the
knights that's a big plus for for deal
he hasn't had to move his Knight on A3
that Knight got offered an Escape Route
it just got traded but now the C3 Pawn
is under Fire it's under very serious
fire and the obvious move Bishop D4
allows a rook infiltration to see two
after the Rook trade this is where I
remind everybody all that a niche needs
is a draw so his strategy changes
fundamentally I still think he's got
great chances to hold this in the end
game he retained good drawing chances
and even managed to even up the game on
the clock Nihao transferred his extra
Queen Side Pawn to one on the king side
entering a rook in game that was
certainly drawn but was not easy these
pawns are weak on the surface but look
at how the king can defend both of them
from F6 in a way this is like an ideal
Arrangement the rules for Pawn
structures and Recon games are totally
different yeah yeah no sometimes you
have the split pawns and actually it
means if you want to make a pass Pawn
you're gonna need to trade more pawns
than you'd like the more pawns that get
traded off the board wait the more it
helps honey but obviously you shouldn't
trade indiscriminately if you take on
that Force here white gets the connected
ones I think that's a difficult one to
defend if I'm a niche I'm keeping the
tension playing Rook C1 or Rook C5 he's
correct to invest this clock here Rook
C1 is played and you also have to watch
a mouse slip by the way he's investing
time but he's got four and a half
minutes plenty of time he does have a
lot of time just as the draw appeared
clear to Geary and the commentators
Nihao found an amazing sequence to
infiltrate with his rook and break with
the move of the day pawn to F5 on move
103. the one Pawn up rook end game was a
winning one as Gary's King was cut off
and he shortly resigned oh he's Mr F6
and King G4 now the king's going up the
board oh my God the evil bar is showing
a win Rook H1 Rook H1 you have to cut
the king off but then I think Rook won
yeah and then Rook age six apparently
the winning move is F5 you trade the
pawns and then the king being cut off is
actually significant and if you trade
the Rooks in that position at the end of
the line you're losing there's king f8
and you lose oh God apparently Anish had
to play a well-timed E6 E5 stacking the
pun temporarily that was an impossible
move but does he have to find F5 I think
he does because if he plays Rook H6 to
pave the way for his King Anish can
throw his Rook on F1 I think that might
hold F5 is a winning move and and the
hulkin sense that that winning move is
somewhere yeah he's spends unbelievable
I think and he should have tried to keep
the tension make nihal be the one to
take on G5 I think practically that
would have been a lot easier to draw and
you can see the just the I don't even
know what the word is Devastation that
is a lot of money
is into the finals unbelievable turn of
events as
a rook end game and we do see that look
of elation from nihal tsar and I already
congrats to him but unfortunately that's
the end of the tournament for Grand
Master Anish giri nihal sarin now heads
to the chess.com Global Championship
Finals to play Wesley so at just 18
years old nihao's time to shine on one
of the chess world's biggest stages is
now
[Music]